y aquí recibiendo los nuevos huéspedes
luego de una exitosa maniobra de acoplar
los cuatro pasajeros de la cápsula
cruzaron de space explotaron hacia el
interior de la estación espacial
internacional para una tradicional
ceremonia de bienvenida con sus nuevos
compañeros de tripulación
excelente no les puedo escribir cuán
emocionados estábamos cuando esa nave
despegó de esa plataforma y las últimas
27 horas han transcurrido muy tranquilas
así que estamos muy contentos de estar
aquí muy honrados nos emociona ser parte
de esta gran expedición skate expedirse
a los recién llegados son tres
estadounidenses mike hopkins víctor
luther y shannon walker y un japonés
soichi noguchi los cuatro pasarán seis
meses a bordo de la estación espacial su
viaje a bordo del crucero gone del space
ex marca un nuevo hito en los viajes al
espacio es la primera vez que una firma
privada transporta astronautas hacia la
estación espacial internacional
desde el final del programa del
transbordador espacial en 2011 la nasa
ha creado esfuerzos desde spacex y boing
para dejar
sistemas que transporten a los humanos
hacia la órbita terrestre baja todo para
intentar bajar los costos
ese programa de tripulación comercial
parece estar arrojando frutos el cruz lo
hago le ha costado a la nasa menos de
dos mil millones de dólares para
financiar su desarrollo y 400 millones
por lanzamiento en contraste con los más
de 27 mil millones en costos de
desarrollo y casi 2.000 millones por
lanzamiento para el viejo transbordador
espacial los astronautas que están
haciendo historia apodaron a su
transporte como la cápsula resiliencia
con el ánimo de ofrecer una dosis de
esperanza e inspiración luego de un año
particularmente retador en el planeta
tierra